هل تعتقد أن بوتين ممثل عقلاني
، أعتقد أنه ممثل عقلاني
أخطأ بشكل كبير في الحسابات
، أعتقد أنه اعتقد أنك قد تتذكر أنني
أشرت إلى أنهم كانوا
سيغزون كل تلك المئات
من القوات أو أكثر هناك وكان جنوم يعتقد
أنه سيذهب  لغزو
أوكرانيا ، استمع إلى ما يقوله إذا
استمعت إلى الخطاب الذي ألقاه بعد
اتخاذ هذا القرار ، فقد تحدث
عن الفكرة الكاملة أنه كان بحاجة إلى
أن يكون زعيم روسيا الذي يوحد كل
المتحدثين بالروسية ، أعني ذلك فقط  أنا
فقط أعتقد أنه غير منطقي ،
لذا إذا لم يكن عقلانيًا ولا
لم أقل أنه ليس روسيًا ، فقد قال
الخطابات التي أعتقد أنني أعتقد أن الخطاب على ما
يرام ، لم تكن أهدافه أعتقد أنه
اعتقد جيك ، أعتقد أنه كان يعتقد أنه
سيكون كذلك  مرحبًا بكم بأذرع مفتوحة لأن
هذا كان منزل
الأم التي تهرع إلى كييف
وكانوا موضع ترحيب وأعتقد
أنه أخطأ تمامًا في التقدير ، هل
تعتقد أن الوقت قد حان للولايات المتحدة لإعادة التفكير في الأمر؟
علاقة ts مع المملكة العربية السعودية
، وبالمناسبة ، دعنا نذهب مباشرة إلى حيث
ذهبت ، لم أذهب إلى أي شيء يتعلق بالنفط ،
لقد حرصت على التأكد من
أننا لن نبتعد
عن الشرق الأوسط وما كان
بالمناسبة اليوم لقد قمت للتو بإغلاق
الهاتف مع رئيس أه أه
لقد أغلقت الهاتف مع رئيس
وزراء إسرائيل ورئيس
لبنان ، لقد توصلوا إلى صفقة
أعلنوا أنها في حالة حرب  الحرب مع
بعضهم البعض لفترة طويلة ، لقد
توصلوا إلى علاقة حدودية على
طول أه في شرق
البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​من أجل النفط ، وبعد ذلك
سيعقدون اتفاقية
تاريخية ، لقد حصلنا أيضًا على رحلات جوية
للطائرات الإسرائيلية فوق السعودية  الجزيرة العربية حصلنا على
حركة من حيث كيفية تعاملنا
في الشرق الأوسط مع العدوان من
إيران
ولكن لم تكن تعلم أن هناك
ثمانية أطراف أخرى هناك ثمانية أطراف أخرى
هناك لم يكن الأمر يتعلق
بالنفط ولكن  يجب علينا و
أنا أه في  العملية عندما
يعود أه هذا المنزل في مجلس الشيوخ ،
سيضطرون إلى أه
ستكون هناك بعض العواقب لما
فعلوه مع روسيا ، ما نوع
العواقب التي يقول مينينديز أن تعليق جميع
مبيعات الأسلحة هو ذلك الشيء الذي تريده
ضع في اعتبارك
أنني لن أتطرق إلى
ما كنت أفكر فيه وما أواجهه ، ولكن
ستكون هناك عواقب
على وشك أن تبلغ الثمانين من العمر الشهر القادم
عيد ميلاد سعيد في وقت مبكر
كلما أثار أي شخص مخاوف بشأن
عمرك  أنت أكبر رئيس
في تاريخ الولايات المتحدة ، فأنت
تقول دائمًا شاهدني لقد كان الناخبون
يراقبونك الناخبين الديمقراطيين
يوافقون على الوظيفة التي تقوم بها
الناخبين الديمقراطيين أه مثلك بشكل كبير ولكن
استطلاع واحد أظهر أن ما يقرب من ثلثي
الديمقراطيين  يريد الناخبون مرشحًا جديدًا في عام
2024 والسبب الرئيسي الذي قدموه هو
عمرك ، فما هي رسالتك إلى
الديمقراطيين الذين يحبون
ما فعلته ولكنهم قلقون بشأن
عمرك ومتطلبات الوظيفة بشكل
جيد.  إذا كنت قلقًا بشأن ما إذا كان
بإمكاني إنجاز أي شيء أم لا ، انظر إلى ما
قمت بإنجازه ، اسم لي رئيسًا في
التاريخ الحديث قد أنجز الكثير
كما فعلت في العامين الأولين وليس
مزحة قد لا تعجبك ما قمت به
ولكن  الغالبية العظمى من الشعب الأمريكي
يعجبني ما أنجزته
، لذا فإن الأمر يتعلق بإمكانية
القيام بالمهمة
، وأعتقد أنه يمكنني
القيام بالمهمة التي تمكنت من القيام بها.
لقد حصلت على تخفيض التضخم ، حصلت على كل
هذه التشريعات التي تم تمريرها ،
وقلت إنني قلت هذا ما
كنت سأفعله وما زلت
أنجزه ، لقد علمنا بالتعامل معك مع
التأكد من أن المحاربين القدامى  احصل على
تعويض عن حرق الحيوانات الأليفة ،
وحفر الحروق ، مع التأكد من أننا في
موقف يكون لدينا فيه أخيرًا عمل
على البنادق وبالمناسبة سأحصل على
حظر أسلحة الروح قبل أن ينتهي هذا ،
سأحصل على  مرة أخرى ليست مزحة
ومشاهدة